Кисень! Молодці!
Помирають від безвиході і від прогресування захворювання
Але сьогодні не вихідний, блін. Сьогодні законно, все по закону
Якесь таке є в людей завжди відчуття, що зі мною цього не станеться
Ти виходиш до родичів і ти кажеш, що все…
Ми боїмося лікарні, але люди безвідповідально ходять по вулиці і кожен з нас може стати жертвою,
навіть не думаючи про це.
Я не розумію тих людей, які свідомо йдуть у великі скупчення людей,
чи це на якісь концерти, чи дні народження, весілля.
Це що якась рулетка? Це азарт? Це егоїзм!
І щоби я сказав таким людям?
А тут не говорити треба. Якби була така можливість, я би їм робив такі маленькі екскурсії.
Я думаю, це було би більш дієво, ніж говорити.
Коли ми щось говорили про те, що треба буде йти лікувати ковід, були в різних людей скептичні думки,
а чому я? а чому саме я?
У 2014 ми ж (лікарі) нікуди не пішли, а пішли молоді люди з голими руками.
Я взагалі вважаю, що це пішов цвіт нації.
І коли сталася ситуація тут, і там люди пішли навіть не у військовій формі, а тут ми в білому халаті.
Ми маємо прийняти цей виклик.
26 серпня 2020 ми задекларували, що Львівська обласна клінічна лікарня на базі ревматологічного відділення
готова приймати першого пацієнта з ковідною пневмонією. І з цього все почалося.
Я не можу сказати, що ми починали легко. Це 60 людей, різних, які зійшлися в непростій ситуації,
невідомій для кожного, як для лікаря, як для медсестри, як для санітарки. Ти не візьмеш і не прочитаєш про це в книжці,
ти не зателефонуєш до старшого колеги, не спитаєшся і не порадишся.Тут командна гра.
Тут не питання - взяли хворого і понесли всі. Нема "я" і "ви". Нема "я" кожного. Є ми. І результат залежить від кожного.
З першого дня ми були забезпечені всім на 100%. Ніхто не захворів, я боюся це навіть озвучувати.
Я не забобонний, але от все гаразд. Це велика самодисципліна і самоорганізація персоналу. Кожного зокрема.
Важче емоційно, бо тут, на превеликий жаль, все відбувається дуже швидко і стрімко, і непередбачувано.
Та якби вони тільки мали пневмонії. Це є тяжкі пацієнти з коморбітними станами.
Є ургентні операції, від яких не відмовишся, чи ковід + чи ковід – і теж ці пацієнти переводяться в наше відділення.
Кожен складний випадок, який закінчується позитивом, це можна прирівнювати до дива.
Коли пацієнт був на ШВЛ два тижні, а він виходить з реанімації і через 10 днів йде своїми ногами додому і просто каже "дякую".
Як настрій? – Чудовий! – Чудовий навіть? – Краще почуваюся і вже легше набагато!
Це якась така маленька перемога, яка дає тобі заряд рухатися далі.
А найгірше - це безвихідь, це дуже так… Ти виходиш до родичів і ти кажеш, що все.
По телефону це ще одне, але вийти туди за двері - це зовсім інше, до родичів.
Я за той карантин, який був у березні місяці. Бо тільки тоді можна перервати ланцюжок.
Ми добре пам’ятаємо порожні вулички Львова, абсолютно пусті. То чому зараз ми не можемо так зробити?
Кількість пацієнтів буде зростати. Ніхто ж сезонного грипу не відміняв, який теж буває з пневмоніями.
До цього треба бути просто готовими. Станом на сьогодні у нас немає проблем з киснем.
Прошу вже брати маску, беріть маску одягайте для того, аби ми тримали сатурацію в належному…Так, на 99
Якщо від тієї суми, яку ми отримуємо від НСЗУ, змінусувати засоби індивідуального захисту,
змінусувати кисень, заробітну платню, там залишається близько 25% для забезпечення пацієнтів.
Це є мало, і в певній мірі це покладено на плечі пацієнта і його родичів.
Ця ситуація з ковідом ще раз підкреслила те, що ми є всі однаковими.
Всі. Людство повстало перед проблемою, яка вирівняла всіх, яка не вибирає ні за кольором шкіри,
ні за країною, ні за статусом, ні за чим. Нічого в житті не дається просто так.
Може це для того, щоб задуматися?
Я думаю, що ніхто не скаже, коли закінчиться пандемія. Всі чекають цього, щоб нарешті
можна було жити нормальним повноцінним життям.
Я думаю, випишемо останнього ковідного пацієнта і, я думаю, що це буде весело, це будуть позитивні емоції, однозначно.
І це якраз буде одна з перемог кожного, кожного, хто працює і хто є дотичний до цього.